so
as chair of division two of the house
finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
and as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-4
o4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this public hearing
is pertaining to
the merger of the community college
system
and the university system
as defined in hb2
please note that there is no fiscal
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with merchant with
the emergency order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to contemporaneously
listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website
the notice of for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should email lba underscore
fiscal at leg dot state
dot nh dot us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote let's
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
lin if you would uh take the attendance
certainly thank you madam chair uh
representative porter
i'm here in hillsborough my husband is
in the house but not in the room
thank you representative turcotte
representative turcotte is here in my
office
in barrington alone thank you
representative heath
representative heath he is here in
manchester in my home
i'm here with my husband in the other
room and i do expect
a man who's coming to the house to give
us an estimate on windows so there may
be somebody walking around in the back
room
background thank you thank you i'm
representative lynn i'm here at my home
in windham
i'm alone in the room but my wife is
elsewhere in the house
representative murray morning kate
murray is at home in newcastle with the
dog my husband is in the house
probably heading down to his office
shortly thank you
representative petry representative
peter is in his car
on the way to portsmouth at some point
with my wife
no dog thank you thank you
and representative umberg yes thank you
i
am uh in my home in kearsarge and uh
my husband is in the house but not in
the room
okay thank you all very much um i did
hope
that everyone saw yesterday
uh that there was a uh email
from i guess the speaker
announcing that um covet shots
would be available to anyone
that wants them it there's no
age it's all the various categories
and that's going to be given at the
building so i think it said
i didn't pay much attention but i think
it said you had to call
and make a reservation so they
would know exactly how many shots to uh
to have available so yes represent
porter
so representative omburger thank you for
that um the information that i received
was that you had to be 50 years
or older or have a condition to get the
shots
no not for the state house employees
and the representatives it was all
categories of people
you just had to call and make the
appointment okay thank you very much
i'll make sure that that gets corrected
then from what i was told thank you okay
so i just i really want to stress that
especially
if i know we're all getting
a thousand emails a day that makes it
hard and sometimes we
we overlook things but
so please if you have not had your shot
i would just ask that you call and
and take advantage of this opportunity
so uh we will now
uh switch gears to
talking about the um
[Music]
unification of the uh
community college and the university
system
kathy you have something you wanted to
sorry i hit the wrong button uh
don't worry we all do good good morning
everyone
um kathy provencher chief administrative
officer university system i'm in my home
in
merrimack alone um
representative i don't have anything to
present i sent to mickey this morning um
an updated presentation if you will we
um
we presented yesterday to the house
education task force
and the vast majority of the
presentation was the same that you heard
last friday we did have some
additional material in there i also sent
to mickey the um
the state uh appropriations for
higher education support by state that
representative turcotte had requested
and also representative turcotte i sent
joe maron's email to mickey because i
know you had asked for that
and i let mickey know that later today
we'd be providing the request that
representative lin
had on student faculty and
ft uh student faculty and staff fte
trend information so other than that i
i don't i didn't have anything
additional to present
but i'm definitely here to answer any
questions
of the committee okay thank you very
much
susan do you have anything that you
would like to uh
to say to us before we start this
again this interesting journey uh
that's a that's a good way of putting it
no other than i too am here in case you
have questions
uh and need some sort of uh
clarification from the community college
system so thank you for
uh acknowledging me representative
wenberger
oh you're quite welcome i'm very glad
and shannon you always have something to
this morning might be the exception oh
okay
i know good good morning committee good
morning committee
nice to see you all and tom i don't know
you as well as i know shannon but
uh i'll go with good morning committee
that sounded like the appropriate
response at that time
okay great great uh
i think i think that we have um
gone through several things
our initial briefings were about
what we see as
happening with the uh
demographics of the state i think that's
a
a fair way to put it
and that um if i understood
correctly that the governor's motivation
for this was because the demographics
were changing
and um that over the next
five to ten years we're going to see
a significant
drop in in population
um the
area uh tends to
have a higher higher it's probably wrong
one
more effect on the four-year colleges
than it necessarily does on the two-year
colleges
although the two-year colleges do have
a lot of children young adults i guess i
better call them
young adults that enter into
the two-year college right out of high
school
but a lot their large demographic or
a lot are an older population
that are coming back for retraining
additional training a new career field
uh and that that sort of thing which
uh i obviously there are some folks
that decide they want to go back on a
on a four-year degree to change
their their career path
so
there has been a lot of conversation
i think on our part about
form this new group of trustees
to provide
to look at and to
come back to the legislature next year
with a proposal on the unification
and i need to stress
i guess that
as the legislature um
obviously has a thumbs up or thumbs down
uh opportunity
not this year but next year
and i know that the the time
frames are are pretty um
are pretty tight and um
i think the governor said that they had
to be back like
31 december or something along that line
sometime any out next
later on in this year and so
we all know that the um
[Music]
the senate doesn't have the same hard
deadlines
as the house does we also know
that we can get
approval to introduce
at in the house introduce um
legislation after the deadlines
and um so
i think that's something we all have to
all have to keep in mind
that um the
you know the deadlines of you know for
for the house will
probably be sometime in uh early
november
and i would be surprised if uh
the the trustees were able to
finalize all of that by
early november that's just karen
umberger's
thought process unfortunately i have
in in my past life worked on
significant reorganizations and
it's always always tough
i think the other thing that um
many people are concerned about and i'm
just gonna say it
outright is that
um the community college from their
perspective
is concerned about being
um and
i believe that the governor
was
particularly uh had had foresight
because the the the new uh trustees are
made up
of five current trustees from the
university system
and five current trustees from the
community college
and then five trustees that
uh that he will uh thank you
that he will appoint so
um i think that we all
recognize that these 15 people
are going to have a lot of work to do
i mean a significant amount of work to
do
because
what i saw from information dealing with
other mergers of this kind
from from the perspective of
the university and the community college
well let's get a group together and do
this
and so i think that that is um that's a
different we we are embarking on a
different kind
journey than what the uh than what the
other states have done now
i think that we have
sort of agreed we haven't voted on it
yet but i think we have sort of agreed
that uh these new trustees
need uh some
uh i think we talked about 1.5 million
to hire someone to help them work
through this
because um there are
folks out there that that have worked on
these things before
and uh so i you know that's not
we haven't voted on that or anything but
i think that
to me anyhow that makes uh
makes a lot of sense so anyhow that's
sort
of my summary of
what's going on and um
i would ask if anyone has any
thoughts that we share them because this
is kind of like our
last time to really make sure
that we are
understanding where we are and
what what we need to do so
representative
heath i see you have your hand raised i
do thank you madam chair and i
agree with many of the things you've
said but
um first of all i don't want to say that
i'm opposed to the merger
because i know something needs to be
done what i'm opposed to
is the speed at which it's it's taking
i'm also opposed to the fact that we
have failed to level fund both
agencies and then we're asking them to
do
something else i would prefer to see
a slowdown and and
not necessarily name a combined
board immediately but to convene a group
and begin the process and have them come
back with some recommendations
i just am troubled first of all by the
fact that we've
over the years we have significantly
underfunded
both agencies across the country um
we are probably one of the lowest that
supports
our system and our our students have
suffered
from it by the the level of tuition
that's had to be imposed
at both levels and i just think that
it's
it's now we're piling on top
of a trouble system because of our
declining enrollments
another effort to merge the systems
without i think proper
thought about the process so again while
i'm not opposed to it and i'm glad to
hear about the 1.5 million because i
think that's a critical element
um i just am concerned and
i i would ask that we consider
a little bit of a slowdown in the
process thank you madam chair
yes thank you madam chair and uh
i now that i've had a considerable
amount of time to actually look at this
i have
many points uh i i will agree uh
immediately with
representative heath's comment about the
speed um
i have to assume i haven't been involved
with this in the past
but i'm guessing there has not been a
study commission
or a study committee done on this before
um i i'm very troubled that we have such
a large
policy issue embedded in hb2
um i know we're not supposed to be
policy individuals but unfortunately
this is an hp 2 and it's up to us
unfortunately to
have to deal with it um
i'm just going to go through the issues
that i see and uh
the first one is the actual forming of
a system board of trustees
at this early of a stage once that's in
uh
to me established it's almost going to
be impossible
to eliminate that if the legislature is
not
able to come up with legislation putting
this
uh system together i also as uh
representative he said i'm not opposed
to this
the concept but how this particular
language is going about it i i don't
think is the correct way
i'll start with the uh the makeup of the
board of trustees
while it says and i i sent a couple of
uh
potential uh amendments last night to
you know to kind of calm my concerns
with this if it were to go through
but um you know it 15 members five by
the two years
five by the four years and then the
governor is appointing five
however it's nominated it's by
nomination
by approval of the governor and the
executive council
in my opinion if we're forming a board
of trustees we need
we can't have a veto power on the
two-year college
nominees and we can't have a veto
college on the unh
nominees those should be put there
um we we would expect i would expect
that both of those entities would be
sending their best and brightest
to uh promote their their mission so
i don't like the fact that uh the
governor and the
the um
and the executive council would have to
approve of those individuals
um and just to be clear for everybody
this it would actually be a 23-member
board because there's also the
ex-official members that also get
the other thing was
failure to you know that i i do also see
this as the timeline as being very short
um i i just don't having been involved
with
as representative umberger has said i've
been involved with
some mergers of airlines
and the seniority systems and all that
stuff and i can tell you it's
it's not as a and different uh
uh collective bargaining agreement
agreements merging all that together is
not an easy uh
an easy event i've been involved with
those and it's not easy and there's
years and years of lawsuits and all
kinds of stuff
um but uh the january 22 date
to recommend legislation
you know that's all in good but um
there's nothing in here that was
would say okay what happens if if that
legislation is not approved
and to me if it's not approved the event
one of the amendments i send
sent in was that if it's not approved
then
the enti you would have to dissolve the
entire chapter 188
one this whole new chapter in ormond in
order to eliminate
uh the board of trustees which goes back
to my original point
of i believe this really needs to be
a commission or study
probably a commission i you know i'm not
sure the difference really between the
levels but
this needs to have more more thought
more planning and to just go in and
develop a 15-member board
of trustees to me is seems extremely
premature
okay representative murray thank you
madam chair
um by and large i agree with what i've
heard before i do think that this is
moving a little too
fast um i don't have a problem
with this these 15 people or however
many it is convening to do preliminary
work i think that coming from you know
people from the community college or
from the university
um they're by some of them are working
on some of these issues already
and so i don't have any problem with
that group being formed
i don't know if we want to refer to it
as
the board of trustees of a new system
that may be a little bit premature in
how we name it
i would i agree about slowing down
i would want whatever this group that
comes together to work on this
i and going forward i think that i would
really want to make sure that the
community college is always in parity
with the university in terms of
representation on
this type of board in some of the
instances we've seen before
the populating of that board has been
based on
population of the community colleges or
the university system
which puts the community colleges at a
disadvantage and so i would like to
make sure that the community college and
the university have equal representation
on the board
um i certainly agree with representative
heath
i would love to see both the community
college system and the university system
receive level funding
they are dealing with difficult issues
right now and we're asking them to be
doing more
in terms of working towards a merger i
think the mergers probably has has
um some value and
so i hate kind of pulling the rug out
from under them a little bit or you know
making them do more with less money
so i would certainly try i think we
should try our best
to get level funding back for both
systems um
i don't know if since i don't know what
we're going to be calling this 15-member
group um i agree with representative
turcotte about is it really a
you know are we ready for abort to call
it a board of trustees
and i agree um with him in that the
community college and the university
should have
absolute rights to decide who's going to
be on that board without them being
vetted or vetoed in the executive branch
um i don't know how much money they
would need i'm really glad to hear
um our chair say that you know they
probably need some money going forward
um i think i would i need to think a
little bit more about how much money
that would be 1.5 million
may be a little high to my mind i'm not
sure
they will need help but i
also wonder when will they need help if
they're initially going to come together
to discuss
what this merger should look like and um
what they need to do
to go forward for the merger so those
are kind of my random thoughts but by
and large i'm agreeing with what i've
heard so far with
minor you know discussion points here
does anybo who came
ma'am you you muted yourself muted i'm
sorry
cathy did you come up with the 1.5
or did we
the the both the community college and
the university system
submitted a joint fiscal note with a
range of a million to a million
five that was based on um
susan hewitt and i had had a call with
the director of the new england board of
higher education
and work that had been done in maine and
vermont and connecticut
and i had also spoken with a consulting
group that specializes in higher
education across the country
and so that range of a million to a
million and a half came from those
discussions
albeit i'll admit it it is an estimate
but
thank you does that help representative
murray
yes thank you representative porter
thank you madam chair i want to agree
with the things that i've been hearing
um i just have two points one i really
think it's important that we consider
level funding
both systems while they're going through
this and
the second point i'm a little confused
on
the million to million and a half that
would that be would there be money
available
for a commission
a preliminary commission to hire someone
to help them
um or would that only be available if
it's an official board of directors
do you understand what my board of
trustees rather
i think i think an informal group a
commission
would also need support to get this done
such as the school funding commission
last year
hired someone to help them do the work
and i think that that would be important
if we go that way to make sure there is
funding
for such a commission to get help
whatever happens that money will be out
there
i think you know i mean obviously we're
gonna work
we will put the money in um
and we're getting it off mary's tree
but um anyhow so yes
uh representative turcotte thank you
madam chair
um my first speech excuse
excuse me just a second um we've had
some talk about level funding
what are is that what is proposed
for this year is that what i'm
understanding what i'm thinking of is um
the funding from two years ago there was
a previous budget that we found them at
the same level as the previous budget
that was my what i was what i intended
um i don't know if representative heath
had the same thought
level funding from the previous biennium
does somebody know what that is the uh
the university systems appropriation
this year
is 88.5 million dollars or 88 million
dollars
and the proposed uh
hb1 has it at 84 and a half i believe
i think the other way kathy i believe
it's 88 and a half
down to 84. it so we have a four and a
half million dollar cut
in 22 compared to 21
and then the appropriation in the second
year of the biennium
drops 2 million dollars
compared to the total for community
college and
university system in fiscal 20
too i'm just going to i'll use
i'll use joe's term violently agree
with comments that have been made about
um
level funding for the community college
system in the university system
there is some very very hard work ahead
and we're going to need some runway
to to achieve all that we need to
achieve
in thinking about the future of public
uh can someone from the community
college tell me what your
sorry i'm looking for that right now i
think that our 21
funding presently is
just under 56 million um maybe nikki has
that readily available i'm
looking for the data right now 360. so
55.36
that's 21. 21. yep
and then right now in the governor's
budget we're at 56
million even in uh 22 and then
so if if i'm hearing correctly the
community college is level funded in the
governor's budget
yes i think that's essentially in year
one but then
in year two there's a sort of share yeah
i got that
i got that the uh
where my my feeling on excuse me len for
my feeling on this is that um
we will split the money for 23.
however it works out so that we
um that way if this whole thing
falls apart then we still have
the um the line item in the budget
for both the community college and the
university system
so that's that's another you know
another one of those
changes that we'll need to make or
whatever
okay represent turcotte i'm sorry i i
didn't want to let the level funding
business
go by without trying for
all of us to understand because
this is money that we're going to have
to find
understood i'm not going to speak about
the money issue
um what
um the i kind of stopped my
my discussion of the merger before
to give other people time to speak i i
spoke basically to the structure in the
language of
what's in hb2 uh last time this time i
just want to
hit on a couple issues from um
my point of view as to some of the
downsides i see
to an actual merger um
representative umber umberger mentioned
in her opening statement the word
consumed
and i gotta admit i'm i'm a little
worried about that myself
i'm a product of both the community
college system of new hampshire
and the university uh system of new
hampshire i've seen both
in my opinion the missions are vastly
different
the community college uh
produces graduates who can go
immediately into the workforce
unh sorry unh but i don't see it quite
the same way um and i would hate to see
a merger where the uh
the community college system is
negatively biased
and that's really probably my biggest
concern
about going down this route um i'm i'm
more of a uh supply and demand free
market
kind of guy and i know
in some something i read they it talked
about
um oh it might have even been uh
commissioner edelblut's letter yesterday
where he talked about
um two competing systems
well in my opinion i i'm not opposed to
watching two
even public uh colleges and university
systems compete uh that
that's not a problem for me we know
there's gonna be
decreasing student populations we know
that's coming
i haven't heard anybody talk about it
but the online
you guys got to start planning because
that's there's going to be huge amounts
of bricks and mortar colleges going away
so i i i just see the need for
both unh and uh community college
you're you're gonna have to start
planning for it you're gonna have to
start uh
adjusting to it otherwise uh um
i i see big problems down down the road
so
um those are my thoughts on it
thank you okay thank you i see that uh
matt has his hand raised thank you madam
chairman and representative turcotte
you know we completely agree and this is
why the governor wants to
approach this unification in that
we know what's going to happen in five
years and we should start planning for
that
and optimize the current systems
to be better prepared for that the last
thing anyone wants is for a college to
shut down entirely
and then suddenly a whole part of the
state doesn't have access to those
resources
so by bringing these systems together by
finding those efficiencies
allowing this unified board to look and
make those hard decisions
that'll yield a better outcome for the
state and for the state students
and for the state's businesses the
alternative is that
one of these schools you know is in such
uh financial distress
that they're coming to the legislature
in a crisis mode
looking for more general funds if we are
in that position today
i don't know that we would have those
general funds so by looking ahead
unifying the boards and making sure that
we acknowledge the reality the
inevitability that that crunch on higher
education
especially public higher education is
staring us down in the face
we want to be proactive to to mitigate
some of those worst outcomes
that you very astutely alluded to
but do we plan now or do we have to
uh cathy you have a comment
i do um thank you madam chair i wanted
to um
address the the sense of that we need to
slow down
and i absolutely understand and
recognize
that this this is moving quickly
but there is an extreme sense of urgency
and a new board i think we talked about
this last friday
you task a new board with
developing the vision and the plan and
implementing on
implementing that plan you hold those
accountable
that are responsible for implementation
for the development of the plan and when
we when we
talk about coming back
next year with proposed legislation when
we think about it
if there's a new board created
even if there's no new legislation you
could have
one board overseeing two systems
now i don't agree that that's the
optimal state
but you'd have one governance we'd at
least have one governance structure
uh to to facilitate
the to your point representative
turcotte the planning of of what we're
going to need to do in the future
we are planning for that the bricks and
mortar and all of that but we have
two systems of public higher education
that
absolutely have different missions
but could work better together to plan
on what the future
holds
thank you uh susan you have a comment
i do i appreciate hearing the
representatives points of view
and i wholeheartedly agree with the
notion that there's more planning
that needs to go into uh this discussion
a whole discussion about what the
mission of this new board would be
um given the comments that i've heard
um i think of the coordinating council
for higher education in the state of
maine
is it possible to put together a group
of people
that particular board consists of the
board chairs
and the chief executives of the three
major public
higher ed systems and charge that board
with some of the things that you've been
talking about
looking for an increase in the work that
has already begun with the synergies
committee
um i i so very appreciate that many of
you have a good sense
of what the priorities are for both
systems but in my case i'm rather
prejudiced and think about the community
college system so thank you for that
while there is absolutely a level of
urgency the community college system
does not
see this crisis in the same way many of
the slides that have been provided come
from
two books written by nathan grah who's a
demographer
this most recent one that's come out
speaks about the agile college
and he sees two kinds of colleges that
have major opportunities
in this current environment one uh
set are the elites the harvards and so
on of the world
but the other set of the community
colleges and it really gets to the point
that yes the number of people who are
graduating from high school
in that you know those 18 year olds that
group is absolutely diminishing
but there still are many people within
the state of
new hampshire in fact close to 70
percent of who was served by the
community colleges
who are in fact outside of that
traditional 18
to 22 year old and i i i think back to
um actually time before i was in the
state of new hampshire when new
hampshire began to lead
in the area of information technology
and the number of people who came into
the state at that point
i'm certain that given all of the
planning that's happening within our
colleges but more importantly within our
businesses
is in fact going to bring in more people
well those people that come in are in
fact the people
who are served whether it's a short-term
credential or a longer-term certificate
or degree
by the community college while i'm
speaking i want to take a slight left
turn if i may representative umberger
and absolutely this is your time
well thank you i appreciate that um our
executive committee voted a couple of
days ago to
proceed with our chancellor's search i'm
going to try to retire again
this will be my third time and i'm
fortunate this is not baseball
um but we absolutely in the community
college system
need a leader and so um
the our board had a whole debate about
whether it should be a permanent
appointment or it should be an interim
and and where the board came to is a
permanent appointment
but with only a two-year contract
because when we read the legislation we
can see that this
new entity would not be fully
operational until
july 2023 so i wanted you to hear that i
i was frankly surprised when we talked
with the search committee
apartment company about this and
the individual said susan it's a great
pool there's more than 66 candidates
um of whom they've qualified about three
dozen
as really being well qualified
exceptional people they have been
communicating with the whole pool
and people have come back and said you
know a two-year experience
would be a very legitimate experience on
their resume
so i'm actually optimistic that we're
going to be able to find my successor as
somebody
uh you know granted things have have
changed if
we were looking for a chancellor a
couple of years ago we wouldn't be
adding
the conversation about potential merger
and so on but
um i wanted you to hear that for me i i
i wanted you to know that
um we're taking this bill very seriously
we're not in any way
thumbing our noses but we are
acknowledging
the system nature of the community
colleges that
we have a situation where the chancellor
leads the president's report to the
chancellor the chancellor reports to the
board
and we need to continue that so thank
you
well thank you that was uh very
interesting news
uh do they have any idea how long this
is going to take
i know you've done quite a bit of work
we have we have um so at this point we
have the pool of candidates what's
happening this week
is that the company is reaching out and
explaining and so we're on track to
identify
somebody by the beginning of june at the
latest
so that this individual would be you
know coming into the position
sometime in the month of july i would
estimate
thank you very much uh representative
you have your hand up
i do thank you uh just for the
administrators on the line are
on the call and matthew also but to be
clear i'm not opposed to
looking at this my opposition
is to the way it's structured currently
and that is
maybe matthew you may not have been on
the line earlier but
it's by forming a tr
a board of trustees at this point to me
is
to me is premature we can we could do a
lot of the same things
in this proposal by doing it with a
commission the timeline would be the
same
i'm assuming the funding would be the
my mike's big problem is once you
appoint get this border
trustees in there and if nothing
no legislation is passed
other than dissolving the entire chapter
how do you get rid of that board of
trustees and go back to the two separate
entities if that's the will of the
membership
uh the legislative legislature
so that's just the only point i wanted
to make on that i'm not opposed to
looking into it i'm just opposed to the
uh represent sorry kathy you
you haven't been elected yet but there's
there's hope for the future
no um
just following up on susan's comments
let's remember that 18 to 22 year olds
turn into 24 to 30 year olds
so while the demographics drop that
flows through so
just just to make that point that it's
not the community college system isn't
immune from the demographic drop
that it's maybe it's a delayed a couple
years
maybe um but just just to make that
point
that one more comment i completely
understand and
appreciate the sentiment that that
a study commission in all likelihood
the work won't start until
the study commission issues a report and
and and it's still it's deliberated by
the legislature we
there wouldn't be a start to the work if
you will
i don't believe under two separate
governance structures
until the complete so we're probably
delaying the start of the work
uh represent murray thank you madam
chair
um i don't know where exactly to direct
this possibly to
kathy i appreciate
representative turcotte's concern about
this being a board of trustees
i'm also leery about another study
another commission
i think that there is work that can be
done
kathy or maybe susan also has this or um
anybody is is there another way of
describing this
entity that maintains the appropriate
representation
and can get the work done but addresses
is there another way of describing other
than board of trustees is there another
way that we can
talk about this group
go ahead susan i'm sorry thank you um
yeah and that's that's why i'm
suggesting that uh
this uh committee think about a
coordinating
council um i
i'm so hesitant to speak because i don't
want to turn this into
uh the community colleges says this and
the university system says this and we
put you
in the middle that that is not um
going to be helpful for for our state if
we end up
in in that kind of a position i'm
suggesting a coordinating council
which is effectively the synergies group
on
steroids um there's nothing to say that
the first priority of a coordinating
council consisting of people from both
sides and and various independent people
couldn't start from the place of we want
a more efficient organization
we want a stronger combination of the
community college and the university
system
and we and i suspect the university
system are going to continue to work on
being
more efficient more effective with how
we use the resources that we have
i was able to detail last time i spoke
with you that
you know our work on shared services and
shared programs
and our cost cutting on the
administrative side
we we do have the advantage of the
community colleges
you know we when we've got more students
we grow more faculty and staff when
we've got fewer
we fold up our tent and and we'll
continue
to respond in that way so and if if what
this body says is the two groups need to
get together
and do much much more planning on what
it would you know
what's the most feasible answer for the
state then then i
you know we can we can do that um
with a little bit more of a reasonable
timeline
and you know create something that has
teeth
uh to look at this i really appreciate
representative turcotte's comments
about not creating a brand new board and
then
having to you know potentially uh go
back to original boards
we're coming out of a pandemic i have to
tell you that the
the community college board is essential
to the health of our community college
system right now
we have representatives from all of the
major industries
we are anticipating you know major grant
opportunities coming from the federal
government
frankly we need those people to help us
to respond not only to the opportunities
within our state but the funding that's
becoming available to us
when the community colleges had the
tact grants during the obama
administration
that is what totally built not only the
advanced manufacturing sector within the
community college and brought it up to
um you know the
current standards without a cost to our
state
but that's also what built cyber
security what built
the non-credit side they were very very
helpful
funds that that gave us that step
forward
so while we're talking about the state i
also don't want us to lose
the opportunities that are manifesting
themselves right now given
yes tom you have your hand up thank you
madam chairman if i
just wanted to perhaps follow up on one
point susan had just made
so again i think you you know where the
university system stands generally on
the proposal but in the event that the
committee is moving towards
uh potentially appointing some kind of
overarching commission one point that we
do i think would be important
is the idea of teeth as susan suggested
and one thing the committee could
perhaps consider
is looking at the governor's framework
and essentially
putting an effective date on that
framework out
some number of months perhaps right so
that ultimately
law is going to force this transition to
happen
in a way that doesn't allow a study
committee to do work
in in you know essentially through the
legislative process
have this drag out longer and longer if
the committee were to
pass something that says yes there will
be a coordinating committee however we
want to call it
however on x set date sometime in the
future
perhaps it isn't the end of this current
fiscal year as the governor's proposal
is
but maybe it's six months after that or
however that
what the governor's proposed does go
into effect so
it could that could be stopped by
legislative action
but it actually would make it so that
the momentum
is going forward absent you all stepping
in
legislatively to stop it um so there
would be sort of that release valve if
things
were not going as you all had hoped and
others had hoped but
it is the it takes more work
to do that as opposed to just letting
time pass and then it happens
thank you representative yeah i think to
uh tom your
your point um combining your point with
uh
susan's uh i i i like the idea
of the uh coordinated counsel i mean
honestly you could insert the words
coordinated counsel
on on line 15 at the very beginning of
this chapter
188 uh you know make the changes within
it
so it it everything is uh synced up with
that name
uh and a few minor changes and you get
this
you have the same the same animal
only again my biggest concern is when
you get to the end of this if the
legislature
get goes thumbs down on it you don't
have to
mix an entire 15-member university
system board of trustees you know so
i think tom the second part of tom's
comment was
include something in there that there
will be a a board
formed at x date
that you'd have a coordinating council
and then a board would be formed
at some three or six months later and
then
the legislature could unravel that
in the next session but not to leave out
the concept
of a new board is going to be formed
i i think you could put language in
there that would uh
say the intent of the coordinating
council is to create a board
without actually saying one shall be
created
um again i i see a problem anytime you
you
put something that says there shall be a
board if the legislated
legislature determines that's not the
way they want to go
i don't see why you put that in there
um i would if you don't mind
i would like to ask
[Applause]
[Music]
representative turcotte representative
heath
um represent murray
and uh representative porter who seemed
to be on this
side of slowing down a little bit or
changing
to um put something together
for us to look at
on um on monday
okay or you know monday or tuesday we
can't
we can't go much beyond tuesday um
i mean i've listened to all of the
comments
um and i i respect your position
and so we need to um
we need to move forward with uh with
something
with with whatever it is that you're
uh that you're thinking about so that
we can i don't want to you know
i don't want to vote to
eliminate this section okay which of
course
is a vote that could be taken um
and um you know so if if you
could get that together um
and it doesn't have to be you know every
word correct or anything like that
we just need to hear where
you know what you're what you're
thinking and
there have been several proposals made
by
you know several different people and um
we just we just need to get it down on
on paper
that you can that the four of you anyhow
can agree with
represent yeah um absolutely i have no
problem doing that i'd be happy to work
on it with uh
with the ladies no problem um my i
also suggest that if matthew
susan kathy or whoever you've heard what
we've discussed you know where we want
to go with this
um if you would like to provide
your thoughts on what the language would
look like look like
uh and have that to us by say saturday
sometime
that would also help out and maybe we
can incorporate
you know some of what you think into it
but and then produce a product that
we'll be sure to um to do that
um might i also suggest you you know i'm
the cfo right so i always come back to
the money
i i'd also suggest if there is a
willingness to have
some dedicated resources for
i'll call it integration planning that
maybe another
class line be added to this
unified pau that was in the budget
for integration planning and
it could be expended whatever way this
ends up
whatever whether it's a coordinating
council or board however this
plays out at the end of the session
there'd be a line item
separate line item one-time funding um
rather than embed it within the
university system appropriation the
community college system appropriation
just a suggestion i think that makes
sense
um seems to me we are going the way of
the coordinated council so that i think
that would
need its own funding uh as to the amount
i'll leave it up to
whatever yeah i understand
mickey did you have a comment uh no i
was just going to add that
if uh if it's the will of the division
to appropriate any money for this
purpose we would probably just include
it in house bill 2
to keep the house bill 1 appropriations
for each system clean and then that way
it's specific to the purpose of
we'll have to talk about the level
funding
for 23
okay oh for the university yes the 22
monday's gonna be a busy day uh
representative petry
can i yes thank you madam chair uh
i'd like to ask miss provencher how
would she protect the community college
system
thank you representative for the
question and
and similar to um what joe mentioned
last friday
the board has proposed
had an equal number of university system
nominations if you will and community
college system nominations
another important part of this um
with any board and and we discuss this
at the university system board is that
all
trustees have a fiduciary duty
for due care for the entire system
uh it's it's um as a fiduciary you
you can't just specifically be concerned
with
one constituency or another
our board now has i think there are four
unh
alum two plymouth alum and
it's part of the training we hear from
the attorney general's office our
general counsel gives training
those trustees can't come to the table
only concerned about the institution
from which they represent
it's it's a fiduciary duty of care to
consider the system
as a whole you uh follow-up
have you have you looked at other uh
failures in uh other states
of the 20 states that we've talked about
have you looked at any of those
and uh gleaned any information that
would be helpful to us
i think that the um the n chems report
that the community college system
provided to division two
with with the challenges and pitfalls
that have been experienced in
connecticut and alaska and minnesota
provides a really in my opinion a good
road map
on on the issues we need to avoid
in in planning what's best for public
higher education
in new hampshire there's a keen
awareness
on i think on the part of the community
college system and the university system
of the important missions of both
systems
and the benefits that those bring to all
granite staters
employers students families
uh so i i
wholeheartedly understand the the
concern
about consumption if you will
but but we're we're all hearing that
concern
understanding that concern and committed
to that not happening because we
recognize the importance of both
missions
okay is uh does anyone else have any
comments okay
seeing none i would like to uh
take a five minute break if we could
kind of summarize where we were
yesterday
and where we're going for uh
monday so if nobody has any objection
we'll just
uh if you just want to listen you're
more than welcome to but
uh we're not going to talk anymore about
this um
combining today okay so i think that the
the folks that have agreed to do
something will
do something and um i'm not sure whether
it's going to be monday or tuesday but
it'll be
i'll let you know as soon as i see
whatever
comes out from from this group so
okay so thank you thank you very much
yeah good luck thank you have a nice
weekend everybody
oh it's thursday have a night take
friday i'll give you friday off
youtube okay
all right so uh mickey i think you
are up to discuss exactly
where we are and
um
what kinds of things that we can maybe
uh vote on on monday
if um i know mary representative heath
is not going to be available
but there may be some things that she
uh would agree with us
and we could at least get those out of
the um
out of the way on monday so okay go
ahead please
sure so um everyone should have received
the documents that i sent last night
which were updated with
the committee's recommendation or
recommended votes from uh
from yesterday's session as far as any
straight up budget decisions at this
point there's really nothing outstanding
that doesn't
affect either highway or general funds
so
i know there's been some members
considering some amendments to bring
forward
for another work session and um what i'm
envisioning i'm gonna try to
i'm gonna try once again to share my
screen here i know we struggled with
this last time
um
anything you guys see anything you're
good okay
so so i'm what i'm kind of envisioning
this document
for monday or possibly tuesday will turn
into is
things that none of the members on the
committee would like to make
an amendment support an amendment for
i'll probably remove them just
just really to focus on what is still in
play so for instance
um safety's additional prioritized needs
like i mentioned yesterday there's like
59 items there
i don't think i'm going to carry all of
those any longer on our working
documents unless a member is
i'd like to you know propose adding one
of them and then i'll detail what that
is
so this this document here will probably
look a little different come next week
um as far as the house bill 2 did it
switch over to the house bill 2
can you see this okay so
so we did uh um approved some sections
adopt a couple amendments yesterday
so there are still quite a few sections
in here that are
straight up house bill 2 that we kick to
policy committees that
uh represent number kick to the chairman
of the policy committees to review
that don't really have a direct budget
impact that were
would probably be pretty easy to do
today or monday if you wanted for
instance the
definitions relative to aeronautics or
the
federal funded real estate disposal of
assets for
um d.o.t that clarifying language um
and then there's obviously some other
bigger issues that we're probably going
to have amendments to
next week and this section down here
with the amendments i still have a
couple of the amendments that
representative umberger
wanted to distribute yesterday or two
days ago which i did
this listing here will increase as
amendments are drafted and some of the
members on the committee want to offer
amendments so
anything that folks want to bring
forward for the committee to consider
i'm just going to add to this document
here so this may grow to two pages you
know once we get everything on there
but this will be the document that i
update daily for next week just so
everyone's clear
as to what we've done through that point
and what is still in play
there are there any ques oh i'm i'm
sorry verbs on peace if you would go
ahead
thank you thank you chair my question is
basically from mickey so
mickey you'd like um by monday
to get any amendments that we would like
to
see come forward to this committee by um
either sunday night or monday yeah the
sooner the better i mean if it's over
the weekend i could update this document
for our monday work session
you know add things on there underneath
maybe an amendment gets worked on and
doesn't get added till monday and then i
can do it for tuesday but
um i'm just thinking it could get tricky
if we wanted to discuss and bring
forward an amendment that
i don't have through me and it's not on
here now you're talking about another
document on it you know so
in a perfect world everything that
committee is going to work on we could
at least have on one central document
just so we're all clear as to
kind of what what is possibly going to
be discussed on a given day
okay thank you so uh mickey
these don't have to be finalized
amendments correct
um i'll try to get them drafted if i can
but if
you know if it's just a word document
someone types up or just a concept and
we want to at least discuss
discuss it on a work session day then i
can go back and officially
adopt an amendment you know with a
number and everything we can handle that
if it's a super simple thing like you
know the committee wants to delete the
section relative to
the liability for obstruction for injury
on a highway
i can just you can make a motion and
tell me to do that i don't have to draft
an amendment that delete you know
so um we can kind of play it by year and
it's really up to you
representative bumburger how you want to
handle that kind of stuff moving forward
for me to keep everything straight make
sure nothing falls through the cracks
this system kind of works
and it's worked in the past too so
yeah no this this is good i i just want
to make sure that
we all understand um
what our expectations are for monday
[Music]
so that we can um you know
really move forward and uh
representative heath
if there is anything on these two pages
that you agree with
uh would you mind just sending me a
quick email
that says you know i'm gonna that way we
can at least
get those things off off the list on
monday although you won't be here
okay thank you madam chair i may be that
i um
might ask to get someone to um sit in my
place just in case
madam chair thank you okay that's fine
it doesn't
it doesn't yeah i just don't want us
have so much to do that i understand
yeah yeah
you know i'm not i just think it would
be
better and again i'm not i'm not looking
on monday to take up any of the
hard things so to speak um
it would just be the uh relatively
uh easy things that we could
all sort of agree with okay
uh representation yes uh thank you madam
chair
uh is there any reason um that we could
not
knock out some of these that are on here
now i think mickey had mentioned
like the uh definitions uh unmanned
aircraft and some of these
easy ones is that the intent
well i think that's what uh the problem
okay he's um he left
because he had something else he needed
to do
and um so i would rather have the clerk
here
to record um record the votes and i
long
thank you madam chair that was basically
what i was going to ask
um can we at least look over those
sections to see what they are
so when it does come to a vote we just
vote
i don't remember any i was not here when
anything was discussed about aeronautic
definitions
or disposal of federally funded real
estate
so i'd just like to know what those
issues are if we
have them and that kind of stuff
aeronautics thing was basically
discussed yesterday
that that was the extent of it it was
just
concurring that it needs to stay in
there that was all
okay represent petrie did you have a
hand up
yes i did madam chair but uh
representative turcotte
ask the same question thank you
okay so um
if we could let's let's just
look at um hb2
okay um and then we'll
go on to hb1 um
the first one was uh free and reduced me
meal eligibility for adequacy
and i think until we hear from um
the doe on monday that i don't want to
pursue that at this point
um the public school
infrastructure fund
um
oh that that was a transfer of the
public school infrastructure fund to
it's in there now right mickey
it's it's in the bill now transferring
15 million dollars per year from the
education trust fund to the public
school infrastructure fund
okay but the public school
infrastructure fund is not
currently in the um
education trust fund no it's a separate
and distinct fund
so this would just move 15 million
dollars from
the etf to the public school
i'm not i'm not ready to handle that one
yet because
we've got uh we've got several issues
that we need to
uh need to look at
okay obviously the next one
we're going to pass over all right uh
61 um the liability for obstruction or
injury to the highway this is that civil
um liability thing that we that we
talked about
and this was the argument of
prospective or retrospective
the highway people that the reason they
needed this is because of
and so they need to be able to
finalize their insurance claim
representative
yes thank you madam chair um the only
question i had on that i wasn't here
for that presentation um on line 28 the
section three
had you all discussed the impact of
retrospectively
we didn't have a huge discussion on it
but it was from d.o.t
that they wanted uh they needed the
retrospective in order to
file claims and they've been having some
difficulty
with that because of the
current language in the law however if
you would like someone to come and
speak to that uh we can do that
the only reason i asked it it says
retrospectively but it doesn't say how
far
back retrospectively so i was just kind
of curious as to
you know how far they are looking at
doing that
that would be my only concern okay
uh mickey can you call over to dot and
ask them that question
i can and um i did also reach out to ols
to get their two cents on
retrospectively and it is
in their what they told me is uh
highly unusual to have retrospectively
appear in rsa
um and then you in most cases that they
did find the term retrospectively it
explicitly said
shall not be applied retrospectively so
um
i can share that tidbit of information
that i got from the drafting attorneys
but i can also reach out to dot to get a
further information about their
perspective of this
okay did did i send out the
i i'm not sure i know i saw it but i'm
not sure if it went to the whole
division
okay i see people shaking their heads so
i i will find that someplace
on my computer and send it out
okay uh the aeronautics definition this
was
uh simply i had a sorry go
go ahead represent murray thank you um i
just have a note in the margins here um
there's a senate bill 131 um
which apparently is pertaining to this
do we have um
do we know any more about that or mickey
am i right about senate bill 131
um i can uh check the status of that
bill
and to see if it um it's 134
what i wrote down let me see
i remember they're saying they're trying
to update the statute to match their
practice
i'd have to do a little bit of research
uh 134
is a uh 56 page bill
so i don't think i'm gonna be able to
jump
i think i might actually be able to see
okay now um
i guess we can follow that up but it
just depending where that goes may
okay all right let's see
um the next one
is uh we didn't have any problem with
aeronautics
okay good uh bridge appropriation labs
to the highway fund
the body worn dash camera fund
um i think
we agreed that we were not going to
provide any
additional funds to safety for that
but that they could take some money
out of the fund to pay for
a uh a position and
uh they came back with a position
that was going to be roughly 74
000 a year and
um i suggested
that it would only be the the first
the first year the way the the fund is
set up
uh the attorney general
and the safety guy have to come up with
rules
and whatever they're gonna do and so
i felt that the um the time
frame or the amount of money that they
could withdraw
would be 18 months worth of salary
because right the fund goes away
at the end of uh the biennium
mickey i'm not sure that fund had a
okay well anyhow we'll
we'll we'll sort that out and um
but we didn't want you know we're not in
a position
where we can add positions i think
that's the
the bottom line there when you say add
positions you mean with with additional
money
yeah and i think it was like you like
you said um
you know a concept is to establish a
position to administer this
but it could be charged to the fund so
that way it's still
a million dollars total safety's just
charging some admin to the fund
to you know right
whatever whatever works in that area
and um we're also
going to have to um kind of redo
this whole section because it's got
too many things it goes from a to b to c
and a and c should go together and b
should be someplace else so i think
mickey's got that on his
um on his uh
and just a quick uh follow-up from the
civil liability the highway
in uh 134 so the senate has it's on the
consent calendar for today
some changes to the same exact law doing
the same thing but
slightly different than how it is in
house bill 2. so at some point
if this were to remain in house bill 2
and senate bill 134
we'd have to uniform those two so they
don't pass on top of each other in
different ways
and i can tell you the senate pat the
senate recommended version does not have
anything relative to retrospective that
paragraph 3
is not there so if you can see the
screen now
this uh right here is not in the senate
plan
so you're on mute representative
represent turcotte you have a question
i do for mickey uh thank you madam chair
um mickey
uh the senate version are you saying
that it has
pretty much everything in here with the
exception of retrospectively
uh pretty close yeah i mean it's it's
essentially looking to do the same thing
it's uh you know probably 15 20 lines so
i don't know if it's word for word exact
but it looks like it's
attempting to accomplish the same thing
so if
uh madam chair if it does that maybe our
best
action on this would be just to
eliminate it
actually uh it's sometimes better to
have belt and suspenders
because we don't necessarily know
that 134 is going to pass the house
or this you know and so it's just
and then if the senate wants to take it
out because 134 passed
then they can do that but from uh
from our perspective it's better to
leave it in
and just for the new new folks on the
committee one of the things that we try
to do
as the budget near completion at the end
of the session is try to recognize
uh changes that are in house bill 2 but
are also
in other pieces of legislation and
remove them from house bill 2.
for instance the bill's already passed
and gone to the governor you know um
just to make sure we don't have
conflicting amendments passed in two
different bills or anything like that
at this stage in the game i think what
representative berger said is somewhat
routine
to not assume something's gonna happen
with another bill still throw it here
and then we'll try to
okay the the next
the next one is um
that let me get to it here page 68.
the higher education trust fund
scholarship fund
i think from our discussion on that
that we were um basically going to
because we currently have
um the what's it called
the the unique program and
it's it's
managed by the colleges i think the only
thing
that i would like to do here
is to add the governor's scholarship
program
to this area so that all of our
all of our scholarships are managed in
the same way
now i don't know mickey if we need
an office in
you state government to handle it or
just
do that so so currently that uh
that scholarship advisory commission um
does administer both programs the
governor's scholarship program in the
the unique program they do have separate
and distinct
funds though so the unique funds follows
this flow of money that we talked here
whereas the governor's scholarship
program does not have a dedicated source
it just gets appropriations in the
budget as
you know so if you
wanted to keep everything strike these
sections it would just be business as
usual and we did
learn that division one is recommending
not adding any funds for the governor's
scholarship program
in the next two years but if you deleted
these sections it would essentially just
be business as usual right but if i
remember correctly
the people that were taught from unique
indicated that that could be funded
with unique money yep so one thing we
could do
is add something to house bill 2 that
allows that advisory commission to
transfer between the two funds as they
that would be my recommendation okay
so i can i can prepare an amendment that
would allow
uh that that group to make
transfers between the funds as they vote
on and approve so nothing that would be
required
legislatively it would just be at the
will of that advisory commission
correct okay just like it is now where
they
where they change the ratio from 80 20
to
70 30. yep and i'm sorry i missed that
whole
somebody froze and i i missed that maybe
it's
my internet's unstable could you just
repeat that mickey please
uh yeah uh representative umberger is uh
talking about we're doing an amendment
perhaps that would allow for the
advisory commission the scholarship
advisory commission to transfer between
the unique fund and the governor's
scholarship fund as they see fit so
nothing
nothing required changing the flow of
money but if they voted to make a
transfer between the two programs they
administered they could
is that the 529 yeah so the unique
program and then
the governor scholarship has a separate
fund so currently they can't co-mingle
funds right now or
send money from the unique flow to fund
the governor's scholarship program
but i think with an amendment that would
enable them to make those transfers then
they could administer the programs with
all the money they have as they see fit
represent porter
thank you madam chair are there
restrictions on the
unique funds i mean the way that program
is set up i understood there were
uh guidelines and and uh sort of
mandates
is there's nothing that prevents that
money from that fund being used for
something that would have been funded
previously by the general fund i just
don't know
so this amendment would essentially
allow
because currently though those two funds
are set up as two state dedicated funds
and there's no mechanism for
that commission to transfer money
between the two i think representative
umberger's
concept is to just give them that
authority to do that and then they would
have to stay within whatever parameters
they set
guidelines around their programs you
know so it wouldn't be a
legislatively required thing it would
just be some enabling legislation to
let that commission run those programs
that they how they would like
thank you representative heath oh thank
you madam chair
um actually this may be a good solution
but
um now the um
unique has their
unique money divided proportionately
for endowment and for scholarships
the scholarship program
it's more wide open so mickey
how would that what would the amendment
on this look like
um what i'm envisioning is just some
general authority for the commission
to vote if they chose to transfer money
between the two funds so it's really
so if they wanted to direct so if you
were calling house bill 2
the proposal was to direct 60 of the
unique money to the new program
so instead of doing anything like that
it just would be enabling legislation if
the
scholarship advisory commission wanted
to move money
to the governor's scholarship program
they could and
can make i go further madam chair oh yes
absolutely sorry
so mickey would i know that often in the
governor's scholarship
program there's a lot of money left over
actually i think there's
um a lot in there right now that has not
been
obligated so that would give the 529
board authority when necessary
to maybe draw on some of those excess
funds and use it for the unique program
is that what i'm hearing i yeah i think
representative murray's idea is just to
allow flexibility for that commission to
move money between the programs as they
see fit
madam chair you're muted
i'm sorry i thought let me unmute myself
here
you were unmuted you just muted again
all right we should we should all have
this down by now
but i guess we don't i had a quick
question
oh certainly go ahead thank you um
is there anything in that language or
would this commission be able to empty
one fund totally into the other fund
in the language that you're proposing
mickey so
yeah i don't have any language drafted i
think the concept was just allow
transfer authority for that commission
between these two funds so
if um in the amendment itself you could
add language one way or another to limit
those transfers or
anything but i think the concept at this
point was just to
give the authority and allow for the
flexibility for that commission to
decide how to prop
how to use those funds as they see fit
right
office of strategic initiative is
managing that program no it's it's um
sorry yeah it used to be that's where
that program used to be the governor's
scholarship program but
it is under the uh the college tuition
savings plan advisory commission now
that was done two years ago
administration so that commission
administers the unique program
and the governor's scholarship program
now and
yeah okay thank you
okay what um madam chair could i just
ask mickey one more question or
one question no no certainly go ahead
just um what about the governor's debt
relief
moves forward yeah we will
yeah we will vote that out first
and then we will replace it with
whatever mickey comes up with thank you
okay so uh
the this is a new one here about
um allowing dot to retain
um excess laps to purchase equipment
that's down at the bottom and i think
that we were all
sort of in agreement on that one without
a problem
and a move dual and concurrent
enrollment program
from doe to uh the community college
um mickey do you want to talk about that
a minute
oops i'm sorry uh matt matt you had a
question
just a question on the excess lapse
for d.o.t um i i wasn't here the day
that that got discussed but
um i'm just curious how the depart how
the committee is defining excess
lapse okay they have a lapse
target right now i believe
and so anything over that target
would be considered excess
they have to meet the labs
that start i don't believe there's a
binding lapse target i'm just curious
how the this proposal would measure it
but maybe it's a separate conversation
uh offline representative just to
make sure that i understand the intent
okay
well dot thinks they right mickey that
they have a target
so i think essentially the concept matt
is
um the lapse estimate on the surplus
statement so what we're carrying for the
highway fund as a whole
would have to be met and then as
determined
you know it's not going to be i mean it
could be clearly just defined it's
you know lapse estimates currently are
not defined in statute anywhere
um determined that dot's portion of that
estimated portion of that
was exceeded any amount up to six
million dollars could be reappropriated
back to the department so
the idea is to first make sure the
highway fund
overall lapse was met but then d.o.t
would only get back
any amount above and beyond their
portion not the entire highway funds
so there is an amendment drafted and i'm
not sure if you've seen it yet but i can
make sure
uh you you get a look at that language
and um
you know any comments you have would be
good appreciate that thank you mickey
i i i'm just look i was looking for
um our uh
[Applause]
or whatever they are um
see if i can find that this is on the uh
the snap though here's the highway fun
um
this one this is an old oh no this is as
of uh
march uh first i've got the language up
now representative umberger
just so everyone's clear on how how the
okay
so
so mickey on on this um the highway fun
budget snapshot yep
what line are we looking at for the
quote-unquote labs oh here at
for 21 it's uh
so i think the the intent of this
amendment
would be that for the highway fund as a
whole so
between safety and d.o.t 28.2
would have to be lapsed to the highway
fund that would meet the budgetary
estimate to make sure
our balance budget balances but then
furthermore
if that was exceeded by amounts
of dot beyond their portion they would
be able to retain that money to
use for equipment for the next two years
that's the idea so it's essentially a
intended to be a net zero budget impact
in that
we're counting on 28.2 to be lapsed if
for whatever reason dot lapses more we
weren't counting on it therefore they
could keep it and buy some equipment
okay so that's probably a little
convoluted but
but we thought uh d.o.t thought it was a
anyhow uh okay the last one on
our sheet here is to
move dual and concurrent enrollment
program
from doe to the community college
and mickey do you want to talk about
that a little bit
uh i don't have a whole lot to add
necessarily it's just it's something
that's come up
doe gets the appropriation and has the
last couple budgets for this program and
pays the community college system
uh relative to students who are
participating in the dual and concurrent
enrollment
um this proposal would essentially take
doe out of the mix
so any amount of money you wish to
appropriate to that program would just
be ccsnh
and they would just administer the money
and that program
we'd probably have to have a separate
line in there too
so the amendment um zero eight five two
h
just replaces uh doe with ccsnh for that
whole
1 80 25 through 29
and then yeah what we could do is either
an appropriation in house bill 2
or a separate line item in the community
college budget
with a footnote making it clear you know
this is for the dual and concurrent
enrollment program
so um we can do it either way
depending on how much money you want to
have we can make that
okay so that's all
of the um the man
i would support that wholeheartedly
okay okay now um
our our next the next big
the next big problem that we have is
how are we going to fund some of these
issues
that that we are um
uh that we're talking about okay i think
that um at least for me
dual and concurrent enrollment is right
up there at the top
the other thing that is up there at the
top is
the um 1.5 million or whatever figure we
come up with
for this uh community college
um unh
whatever um
and
i had yeah that's those are the those
are my
quote-unquote money that is available
the big money i guess is not in the
trust fund right now
but the big money is
uh in the um
public school infrastructure fund
and um we're looking
15 million in two years
and it's my understanding from a
conversation we had yesterday
that most of the things that would come
into the public school
infrastructure area will be
able to be spent with the 350 million
that are coming from the federal
government
okay so um
and again that's that discussion will be
for monday
but um i don't i don't want to
close down the program so i would like
to leave
a little bit of money in here so that
uh if if
a a school
you know need something that is in the
arena of the public school
infrastructure fund
that they could in fact apply for it so
i don't know what i don't know what that
number is
but we'll we'll find one that
uh that makes sense um
so and
i'll tell you what i'm what i'm thinking
and this was by the way
uh my friend mickey's brilliant idea so
he suggested
that we put this money
to um you know we had a bill
monday whenever it was you know that
wanted to
lower these um
the special ed from three and a half to
two and a half or
whatever and
um i know we're not funding the three
and a half
uh but it might you know and if
if we went down to the two and a half
then we wouldn't fund all of that either
but at least from my perspective
that would be something that would
benefit
all schools okay
and not just a few
like the public infrastructure program
is designed to do so
that's just you know uh i don't i don't
remember what the shortfall
was um this year or
last year for um special education three
and a half
um but i'm sure you know that's a number
we can find out relatively easy
so just you know that that is just
sort of um out there
nothing you know nothing final nothing
firm
but just something to uh to think about
represent heath ma'am chief thank you um
i
actually think that's a great idea but
um
last session we um pretty much
fully funded um special education aid
um so um and it's at a percentage of 80
so i i think we did pretty well there i
don't know if we need to put
that much money in would it be um a
consideration to think about
taking some of that money and putting it
into
building aid because where building aid
is is
cut short and i know that we've got a
couple of bills
looking at fully funding building aid
and or my other question is is it
possible to use some of that funding
to go into the um dual enrollment and i
don't know
if that's a possibility yeah of course
it is
okay um mickey correct me if i'm wrong
but i think the number one
project out there is like 30 million
the um there is a pro
preliminary ranking list because the
projects are approved in a
ranking system the first project i
think's around
three million the second one's like 19.
so
i think i think i figured out like 25
million gets you maybe the top three
projects
that's that's about it but maybe we
could put in
three million i don't you know if if
that's the top project that's been uh
do we know i i probably have it here do
we know
if that is um
has the voters have passed that three
million dollar one
um i believe the note that i got on it
was that it's pretty contingent on
state aid okay so it's it's been passed
but
no action is taken or will be passed if
or what you know if state aid is there
then they you know i can't remember the
order if it was a contingent approval
already or the expectation that if the
state was there that
they would okay okay well
hopefully um amy will be able to
uh clear that up for us but that was
that was my my real problem mary or
representative with um putting money
into the um the school building aid
program it was just so enormous
okay and if you know if the uh
whatever we can we can look at um
at the other things and uh again we'll
talk about these
on on monday but probably won't do any
any voting on them but just try to get a
consensus of
where we are represent porter
thank you madam chair i admit to being
confused so
just let me ask if i understand what
we're doing here
in the current budget there's a total of
30 million dollars for building aid
15 million in the first year and 15
million in the second year
no that is not for building aid
for the public school infrastructure
fund
okay all right totally different than
building aid okay thank you for that
clarification
yeah so yeah just say what's in building
aid
is the money for the tail
it's uh yeah 26.9 million
okay so we are talking about
taking 30 million dollars from the
building infrastructure that
education infrastructure fund removing
that because
that money's coming in from the feds
anyway and people will
be able to have their needs met that way
yeah i'm not talking about taking it
all margie so we have a figure there
that we're fiddling around with and
we're trying to decide
where to put it yeah but we're not we're
not fiddling around with it we know
we know that it will be funded
someplace else i i'm sorry madam chair
i don't mean to be believed in the
process i'm just trying to get my
num mind understand what we're doing
here right so we're looking at using
that money
to put into um perhaps special
ed perhaps running start perhaps those
are
things that we're considering
so thank you very much for helping me
understand
okay no problem no problem these are
um these are why
you know where we all try to to work and
think about
what what's going on uh mickey i do have
one other thing
and that was um the amendment
from or the requested amendment from
uh representative weiler
yeah i can uh touch base with him if he
wants us to
bring those forward and i can add them
to our list
yeah i don't i know he wants i know
i don't want to bring forward the 70-31
yeah
that was probably not necessary anymore
i wouldn't think
yeah if you remember the committee or
whatever they are
wanted to be able to set those in rules
and i
i totally agree with that but
the other one was on something else that
got left out of the process somehow or
other
and so i think it was relative to
vacancies on local school boards or some
something
oh yeah on uh not local but on
cooperative school
yeah so i can um i can add that
amendment to
the packet that we talk about on uh the
next time we meet
okay yeah cooperative um
does anybody belong any of the
oh okay so you're in a you're in a
okay you have a question
that i can answer well well well after
yeah after we see uh representative
weiler's amendment will
uh will make don't you not be here
on monday how's that
okay is there anything else that uh
anybody wants to bring up
i i just wanted to kind of go through
those things that are
running around in my head so to speak
so that were um if you are planning to
put in some sort of uh amendments
that we uh you know are
thinking along the same line so
okay with that
[Applause]
nobody has anything else oh sorry
representative turcotte
i just put it up as you're getting ready
to go
excuse me for representative murray
heath and porter look for an email from
me
probably this afternoon and uh matt if
you're still on
on the uh i see you're still there could
you send me um
just send me your email address please
happy to do that
all right thank you does he know what
uh it's available in several places it's
the one on the mickey if you wanna just
loop us together
yeah mickey could probably do that and
then that way
okay well oh i just think i turned
myself no
okay so um we will see
most everyone uh monday morning
and uh representative heath you'll let
me know
okay okay i'm sorry
that's no problem um
yeah so uh tomorrow
i only have fiscal
so you guys have a you guys have a day
when your eyes aren't glued to
the to the small screen and
um we'll see you on monday so